So for today we will be first of all
wrapping up the discussion on indirect
methods uh and then we'll be introducing
the another class of openloop control
strategies which is the one of direct
methods and so specifically remember
that last time we basically were
wrapping up the discussion indirect
methods where uh kind of bird's eye view
we're saying that indirect methods
represents this class of solution
methods. for optimal control problems
whereby we define and derive some
optimality conditions uh which we want
to solve for generating candidates for
optimality. These optimal conditions
boil down into twooint boundary value
problems which we have to solve. uh and
and so what we did is essentially
started to look at computational methods
for solving these twopoint boundary
value problems whereby we first of all
introduced kind of these the solve BVP
uh solver in in Python specifically for
an abstract uh twooint boundary value
problem and so today we will be using
the same solve BVP but this time applied
to an actual optimal control problem
first of all so that you you can see how
this is uh can be done in practice and
then also for you to have a potentially
a useful template for uh for optimizing
or for solving other optimal control
problems.
Um but specifically we were also
mentioning how these solve uh the solve
BBP solvers and most solvers out there
to be honest for to point boundary value
problems assume that we kind of specify
the problem in a quote unquote standard
form. uh where for example uh we were
assuming that the final time is given
and uh known, right? And so we we know
that in general we have been dealing
with optimal control problems where this
is not the case. And so there are uh a
number of tricks that have been
developed in order to basically
reformulate any given structure of our
optimal control problem into a
formulated then amenable for classical
solvers. And so here there is a
reference that I definitely advise you
to uh to check out. It's a fairly old
reference dates back to the 1980s. Uh
but it has kind of all of these
collection of reformulation tricks to uh
to indeed massage the problem into one
that falls under this uh standard form.
And specifically uh uh for today I
wanted to highlight one of the most
common uh kind of settings whereby the
standard form does not apply which is
the one of free uh final time. So again
these solvers usually assume that we
have a given final time. How do we
reformulate a problem where the final
time is actual a decision variable that
we want to pick in order to to be
amenable for this? And in a usual trick
that that happens uh often times in in
mathematics is the one of uh that is
so-called of time rescaling
where specifically we will be
introducing
uh where we we model time t as a
uh kind of normalized time uh tao
times uh ts
uh tao here is is this kind of rescale
time which we wish to uh to use and note
that kind of by this definition TOAO is
T over uh TF and so TF is something we
don't know but whatever TF is uh TOAO
will be defined between 0 and one
because at the final time this will be
TF over TF which is equal to to one so
overall this object is something that is
between uh zero and and one
now of course when we do this um kind of
reformulation, we need to change the
time derivatives.
And so specifically the time derivatives
over to by the chain rule will be the
derivative over times
the to time
df over the to which is indeed
da time.
So essentially we want to uh reformate
the problem in one where the final time
is known. We do this by rescaling time
according to this new rescale time to
which is between 0 and one. So in this
rescale time final time is known and
equal to one. When we do the reform this
reformulation we need to adjust the time
derivatives which essentially entails uh
multiplying our time derivatives by uh
tf.
The other step that in that is entailed
in this trick is then to introduce kind
of a dummy state variable r
which corresponds to the final time and
has trivial dynamics r dot equals to
zero. So r replaces final time uh and in
order to model this in our twooint
boundary value problem we need to have
some associated dynamics with it. But we
know that since R replaces TF for us
which is a constant its dynamics are
trivial and which essentially boils down
to meaning that R is fixed over time.
And so this is basically all that there
is with this trick. So we do these
modifications and replace all instances
of TF with R in our formulation.
So any questions about this but there
will be an example where where we go
into the the details of this.
Okay, that's pretty straightforward and
specifically the example um we will use
will relate to the uh kind of specific
optimal control problem we were solving
uh a couple of lectures back uh where if
you remember we were trying to control
this particle on a line system u where
we wanted to move from a position x0= to
10 with zero velocity to a final
position of the origin. So xdf equal to
zero also with zero velocity. And we
wanted to optimize this cost functional
which was comprised of two terms kind of
one term uh kind of waiting the final
time and one term weighing the control
effort in our system. And uh last week
we derived the solution analytically for
this. But now let's model it uh using
the uh the computational methods. And
specifically notice that here time uh
final time is a free variable. And so we
will have to implement exactly these uh
tricks and reformulations that we just
uh described.
So uh essentially what we're doing here
is we're modeling this uh particle on a
on a line system where as usual for our
solve BVP we have to uh describe first
of all our dynamics. So the OD uh where
actually just to make sure that we are
getting this straight let me quickly uh
re uh restate the solution and the uh
optimality conditions which we derived
for this example. So this is I will go
quite quickly through this because this
is what we did last time. U but
essentially we solved this problem over
here and so if you remember to solve
this we applied our classical strategy.
So we they derived the optimality
conditions which entails uh first of all
um taking our system which in this case
is a second order system and write it in
a as a first order system by augmenting
with one additional state variable. Uh
so x double dot equals u essentially
becomes x1 dot = x2
and x2 dot equals u.
uh then once we reformulate it as a
first order system we could apply kind
of nominally uh our optimality
conditions. So the first thing that we
do as usual is we formulate the
Hamiltonian
uh which for us is 12 EU ^2
plus the costate variables transpose our
dynamics. So p1 p2
uh
time x2
u
which is equal to 12 p u ^2 + p1 x2 + p2
u.
So this is our hamiltonian and once we
have this we can apply our uh optimality
conditions and as usual uh and let's
just write them down. So the first
optimality condition uh essentially
represent the dynamics. So where we know
that x dot is equal to the partial
derivative of the Hamiltonian with
respect to the co-states p and this is
exactly
our dynamics over here.
The second condition entails setting P
dot equal to minus the partial
derivative of the Hamiltonian with
respect to X
where by doing the partial derivative of
the Hamiltonian with respect to our two
co-state variables. what we get is P1
dot equals Z
um and P2 dot
equals minus P1
right so the first one is the derivative
of the Hamiltonian with respect to X1
there is no X1 here the second one is is
with respect to X2 so there is negative
P1
and then the Third optimality condition
entails setting the so essentially
imposing that u has to be a stationary
point of our Hamiltonian which
essentially means that the derivative of
the Hamiltonian with respect to u has to
be equal to zero
which in this case means that b u + p2
has to be equal to zero
and so essentially u is minus p2 over
And so here we can update this as minus
p2 / b because remember that usually
mechanically how we solve this is that
we use this third condition [snorts] to
express u as a function of x and p and
then we do the appropriate substitutions
in our differential equations.
Okay. So these are our conditions to uh
in order to solve these differential
equations. As usual we need uh boundary
conditions
uh where we know the uh kind of the
state at our initial and terminal uh and
terminal we know the initial terminal
state. So we know that x1 at time 0 is
equal to 10. We know that x2 at time 0
is equal to zero. We know that x1 at tf
has to be equal to zero. And we know
that x2 at tf has to be uh equal to
zero. Right? So we have our four
boundary conditions there. We have five
constants of integration that we will
have to um to pinpoint. And so the
additional boundary conditions come from
our kind of master boundary condition
where this depends on whether the final
state or the final times are fixed or
free. And so in this case we are in a
case where the final time is free. And
so if you remember from the past
lectures, this additional boundary
condition essentially entails uh setting
the Hamiltonian evaluated at the final
time plus the derivative of the terminal
cost in the t also evaluated at the
final time setting this to uh zero. Now
I won't go through the derivation of the
terms because we did this already. But
the result of this is the last boundary
condition which boils down to uh minus
p2
ts over 2b
plus alpha ts
has to be equal to zero. Right? Right.
And so here we have our
uh system of differential equations and
here are boundary conditions.
Okay, this everything here is not is not
new. Uh I just re kind of rederived it
so that we can then visually compare uh
what we are implementing in the in the
code.
Okay. Okay. And so going back to the
code, essentially what we have here is
the first we define our differential
equations. Um so if you see x1 is equal
x1 dot is equal to x2. Uh we have x2 dot
is equal to p2 over b. Uh we then have
uh that uh yes so p1 dot is equal to
zero and p2 dot is equal to negative p1.
And then here we already are using this
reformulation trick which we just
derived whereby we are adding this
additional kind of dummy state variable
R with trivial dynamics. Specifically R
has to be R dot has to be equal to zero
and we are rescaling these dynamics by
TF right by the time derivative which we
just discussed before.
Now not uh given this we also have the
boundary conditions specifically
remember that these are fed to the
solver as residuals. So we have x1 has
to be equal to 10. Uh x2 has to be equal
to zero. x1 also has to be x1 at the
final stage has to be equal to zero. x2
at the final time has to be equal to
zero. And then we have our last master
boundary condition here.
Okay. And then so we have all of our
ingredients. Uh so we pass to the solve
uh BVP the uh differential equations. We
pass the boundary conditions. We specify
an array of times of discretized times
which now goes from 0 to one because we
rescaled time to be between 0 and one
uh together with an initial guess for
our uh for our solutions. And if we run
this what we get is that the final time
is equal to 4.47
which if you recall is exactly what we
were getting by the analytical solution.
So if you remember our analytical
solution was looking something like uh
1,800 * b over a uh to the power of 1
over 5 and this is 47.
So we do get the same solution. Um and
we can also inspect the uh the state
variables x1 and x2. So x1 indeed at
time zero starts at 10 and at time at
the final time reaches uh zero
and we see also our control of how we we
get there. Right? So this is essentially
we reformulated this two pound boundary
value problem into its standard form and
solved it through uh numerical methods.
Okay. Any any questions about uh about
this?
Pretty straightforward, right?
Okay. And so, um this kind of concludes
our discussion on indirect methods. Uh
again at a high level we saw how this
entails specifying optimizing conditions
uh and then passing them through a
numerical solver to solve the resulting
twooint boundary value problem. Indirect
methods are historically how optimal
control and the overall field started.
Um and nowadays I would say direct
methods are definitely uh increasingly
more popular uh because of their ease of
use. Uh that said indirect methods have
their strengths. for example, they can
ultimately boil down to having an
analytical solution for your control,
which is ultimately the gold standard,
right? If I have an analytical solution,
then essentially computing an in real
time an optimal control entails a
forward pass through a function, which
is great. Uh if even if we're not able
to solve analytically, we might be able
to just derive the control structure of
our control profile. Remember last time
we were looking at like bang bang
control, bang of bang control which is
uh great for interpretability and just
overall system design. Uh but again
indeed the field of robotics is
definitely moving towards uh direct
methods. So let's uh talk a little bit
about those.
Okay. So usual road map we are al always
in the open loop part of our of our road
map uh looking at direct methods.
>> Yes.
>> Is that also up?
>> It is it is so all the code is up and
you can free to to play around with it.
Yeah.
>> Okay. So direct methods of course in in
you know in in at a high level uh uh
approach to and try to solve the exact
same optimal control problem uh where we
have you know cost functional which we
wish to uh optimize. We have some
dynamics. We have an initial state and a
terminal state here expressed as having
to belong to some uh manifold m of f
defined as the zero level sets of a
function f. um and we have some we might
have some some control constraints. So
here for simplicity I am assuming that
the terminal cost is equal to zero but
it could be trivially added and we're
also assuming that the final the initial
time t0 is equal to zero but this is
mostly for simplicity and for for
notation.
So until now indeed we were approaching
this problem through indirect methods
where we defined and derived optimality
conditions and then we solved this as we
just saw through uh numerical methods
whereby we're essentially solving these
uh twooint boundary value problems
and this is and indirect methods are
referred to as optimized then
discretized exactly because of this
reason the optimality conditions refer
kind of relate to the optimized part and
the solving those for those optimality
conditions through numerical solvers uh
kind of relates with the discretise part
because numerical solvers internally are
discretizing time anyways.
direct methods uh are kind of if you
want the reciprocal of indirect methods
because and in a way I would say that
direct methods are probably uh kind of
the more natural uh approach to uh
approaching optimal control problems if
we were to have discussed this a couple
weeks back because nominally what we do
is we take the optimal control problem
in uh continuous time we discretize time
and turn this into a nonlinear and
constrained optimization problem and
then we can just throw this uh
optimization problem to nonlinear uh
solvers and get and hope to get a
solution out of it.
And the reason why direct methods are
starting to become and are increasingly
more used in robotics is because there
have been a lot of kind of improvements
in the field of nonlinear optimization
that is making the solution of this
problem feasible also in in real time.
[snorts]
There are a number of excellent
references here. I'm just listing a
couple uh for you to um for you to look
at if you're interested.
But so transcription meth and direct
methods at a high level kind of also
kind of are can be subdivided between
two subcategories of uh methods.
And the way these kind of these two
families differentiate from each other
is based on how we choose to transcribe
that is uh discretize and remodel as a
discrete optimization uh uh problem the
original optimal control problem. And so
we have namely state and control
parameterization methods also known as
uh collocation methods and control
shooting. So at a high level starting
from the latter so the control
parameterization methods is that we take
the optimal control problem in
continuous time and we will be
discretizing time and assume that only
the controls uh for us are variables
prone to optimization. So from the
perspective of the optimizer and the
solver only the control variables will
be variables we are optimizing over the
states are computed recursively through
the unrolling of the dynamics.
On the other hand, state and control
parameterization methods again taking
the perspective of the blackbox uh
nonlinear solver will be kind of
transcriptions whereby both the states
and the controls will be numerical
optimization variables we are free to
tune and the solver will be free to
tune. The difference is that in this
case, so the state and control
primitization methods uh dynamics become
constraints that link together the
control optimization variables and the
state optimization variables. Here this
is just a highle picture but we will see
in detail both of these classes in uh
today.
Of course these two families have uh
pros and cons. Um so as you can probably
imagine we are discussing these control
parameterization methods are as methods
whereby only the control variables
become optimization variables and so
these tend to become smaller
optimization problems simply because we
have less variables to optimize over.
Uh at the same time um
these in this family here because we are
enforcing uh so the states are only
recursively computed through the
unrolling and propagation of our
dynamics. Enforcing constraints over
states is uh definitely more challenging
uh because if you imagine the other
approach where both states and controls
are optimization based variables, we can
directly impose state constraints by
just introducing a new constraint on an
optimization variable. We'll see this
more in the in the next slides, but here
just to give you a feel of the pros and
cons of different methods.
So uh simply put if I would say if the
if you have complex state constraints
that you would like to include in your
optimal control problem uh then uh
control parameterization methods might
be a good approach because they're just
simple and you have less optimization
bas optimization variables for your
optimizers. On the other hand, if you
have complex uh state constraints that
you would like to enforce, then probably
state and control uh parameterization
methods are the way to go.
Yes.
>> Uh it's uh it's a big question because
there are definitely hybrid formulations
uh known as multiple shooting methods.
Um I will discuss them in a in a few. We
won't cover them in depth, but I'll
definitely give you pointers for those.
But yes, so you're hitting on a point
where these pros and cons can be mixed
and matched through hybrid methods.
Yeah.
Okay, so let's start from the state and
control parameterization method. So at a
high level what we want to do is take
our continuous time optimal control
problem and turn it into a discrete time
nonlinear optimal control problem
where the way we do this uh is we we do
I mean there are many transcription
methods and ways of discretizing time
that you could uh that we could select
uh but here we we tend to use the
simpler of these approaches which is uh
uler time discretization ation. So in
order to do this step from continuous
time to discrete time, what we do is
that we select a time discretization
meaning we uh discretize time from t0 to
tn according to some uh time interval
which we pick
uh and then for all of our time steps so
t0 through the n which now are just
indices we assume uh what is called a
zero order hold on our control namely
that the control between uh ti and ti +
1 is equal to uh ui. So we assume that
the control is fixed in between a single
time interval.
Um let me
so the sec the other thing that we need
to do is um essentially we use uler
integration to integrate the dynamics
[laughter]
and remember that so the dynamics
uh x dot of t equals fx
u t. Uh now we can approximate this as
uh x of t + delta t minus x of t over
delta t.
And so from this what we can essentially
write is that
xt plus delta t is equal to xt
uh plus delta t * f of x u t
right and in this slides I'm calling uh
delta t H.
>> Yes.
>> Definitely. Yeah. Here we're just going
for simplest approach. Uh but you could
think of more sophisticated ones.
[snorts]
>> Uh yeah. So at a high level again we
want to go from continuous time
formulation to the discrete time
formulation. We do this by discretizing
time. So selecting a range of indices
that represent our time. Um we assume a
zero order hold on our controls. Uh and
approximate our uh continuous time
dynamics in this way. And then the last
thing that we have to do is also
discretize the cost which is here
represented by this integral. Uh but
notice that
if we consider the integral between ti
and ti + 1 of g x
ut in the t. Once we are assuming that
we have this zero holder hold on our
controls. uh then the integral between
so the cost between ti and ti + 1 this
is essentially a constant right
and so we can approximate this as g of x
u t * h
right because we can take g outside of
the integral and so we know that we just
call this uh basically the integral
between a single time step as page
[snorts]
and that's done basically right so
you know then you you could say why even
bother spending you know three lectures
on indirect methods if this is all you
have to do to solve optimal control
problems uh again we we said indirect
methods have their their their benefits
um I would say especially now in the age
of of LLMs to be honest Um,
you know, I'm sure we all know that LLMs
can do a great job at solving these uh
these PMP problems. Uh, you know, aside
of from our homeworks, of course. uh but
you know the point is that I think
through LLMs there is also this notion
where we can definitely accelerate the
design and development process in
characterizing the optimal the
optimality conditions which is arguably
one of the cases why people are going
for these indirect methods in direct
methods in the first place because it's
just simpler. Um anyways this is a
parenthesis uh but so this is basically
all that there is to it to uh on the
state and control parameterization
method. Um any any questions on this?
We'll see an example shortly on how this
is implemented in practice. But any
questions on at a high level what we're
doing.
Okay. [snorts] So indeed let's see this
in practice.
So
um let's solve this problem of crossing
the uh the river known as Zerlo's
problem. uh you have a version of this
also in your pet set and specifically
the setting here is that we want to
cross from an origin point to uh another
destination point on the other side of
the river. uh the river has some flow
which is uh zero at the two extremes and
stronger in the middle.
And specifically here we are assuming we
have a constant forward velocity B. And
the control for us is represented by the
angle between the forward velocity and
the uh and and you know and the flow.
And specifically we want to reach this
task by minimizing the control effort
expressed as the squared of our uh
control variable u. Why does the angle
represent a notion of control effort?
It's because if you imagine taking the
180° uh angle with respect to the flow,
this is when you're doing maximum effort
because you're essentially going exactly
against the flow. If it's zero, you're
following the flow and then you have no
cost. So this problem essentially models
the fact where [snorts] we want to reach
our destination point on the other side
of the river uh while minimizing overall
control
>> effort.
I guess
like
you go
that
I guess your what would be the words and
acceleration bounds are like how far
>> yeah so here we don't assume we have
acceleration meaning we assume we have a
constant velocity v and we are
controlling this angle uh and we assume
our angle is has to has some bounds so
we have some ux yeah
does this answer your your
Okay. So here we are indeed defining our
problem. So we assume that TF is 10. We
have uh our uh final uh coordinates 10
and five. Here we represent the flow
through this lambda function where
ultimately if
um y is equal to l. So uh we are at the
upper extreme of our river this is equal
to zero. If uh
if y is equal to zero this is also zero.
Right? So this basically encodes that at
the two borders of the river the flow is
zero and it is maximum in in between.
So here we are representing our
optimization variables through basically
a concatenation in a vector. So our z
variable represents all of our x y and
u's where xy is the position that we
have on the plane.
Right. So this is our river.
This will be X and this will be Y where
this will be this point would be L and
this and this would be M.
Okay. And so first of all we the we
introduce and we define our bounds for
our variables. Specifically the x's have
to be between 0 and m and our y's have
to be between zero and l.
And for our controls we are bounded
between negative ux and ux. Right?
We define our cost function as the
square the sum of the squares of our uh
u variables um multiplied by h according
to our discretization
and then we define our constraints
specifically our dynamics on the x
variable uh such that the states x i + 1
are equal to x i plus uh h times our
dynamics
Same thing for the y. So y i + 1 is
equal at y i plus our flow dynamics.
Uh and then we have the initial and
terminal constraints. Right? So we
basically say that the first variables
of both uh x and y have to be equal to
zero and m or l respective.
Okay. And so is this clear how we are
basically mapping from the actual
formulation to this code?
>> Yeah. So ML is is this point over here,
right? So this would be our coordinate
ML and we start from 0.
>> Is the X the
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yes. So is your state here or Z?
>> Uh in this code we are basically
defining Z
as the concatenation of X Y and U.
>> Uh this is just to handle it. Okay.
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
>> Yes.
If this model we're completely noiseless
is perfectly described propriet
solving it the same way but it
>> it's a great question. So here we're
assuming kind of the full openloop
strategy where we assume the dynamics
are perfectly known. Um, of course the
moment in reality dynamics are never
perfectly known. So usually what happens
is that your control stack will
definitely have a hierarchy of modules.
Maybe you would have some openloop
planner which basically produces a rough
plan that I would like to follow. But
then in real time when I'm actually
deploying I will probably have a closed
loop module which basically tracks this
plan. This closed loop model will then
be you know tasked with the pro the
problem of
say that this is the path that I decide
but in reality I will be bounced off
this path the closed loop will tend me
to steer towards my nominal path.
>> Yes. So this is one way uh one way is
handling it through closed loop and I
would say that in general any deployment
has a closed loop uh flavor to it. Uh,
of course you could also do a more
sophisticated openloop planning where
maybe I have some notion of the
uncertainty which I can capture through
some random noise random variable W
which might be you know maybe assuming
it's kind of gash and distributed or
something of the like uh and then come
up with more sophisticated planning
strategies.
Okay. And so we have all of our
ingredients. We need an initial guess.
Uh and so here we just come up with a
pretty nonsensical I would say initial
guess. So our y x's and y's are set to
one for all the time. Uh and our u is uh
basically five of the max that we can
solve. It doesn't have to be feasible.
It's just an initial guess. So if we
um [snorts]
if we run this what we get is this uh
solution over here. So you can see that
uh indeed we go from uh zero at time
zero to uh 10 five which is how we
defined ML following this sort of
trajectory and this is a visualization
of the optimal control profile over
time.
Now note that in this case we were
essentially assuming that our UMAX so
our bounds of our controls was equal to
one
and if you look a little bit more
closely at our control profile we never
really reach the boundary right so this
bound on our control is basically non
enforcing or non-restrictive so let's
try to
rerun this but now taking a slightly
more restrictive um which is 75 which if
you note is slightly below kind of our
current optimal control profile.
>> Yes. So U for us is the angle and so we
are indeed assuming uh yeah
so if we just run this first of all it's
taking a little bit more time which is
never a good sign and then we see that
it basically produces uh garbage right.
So um we are not even starting from our
initial point. Uh we're not reaching our
final point. Uh you know basically lost
in the river. Um and this is also what
the optimizer says right so the we don't
reach a final a final solution. And this
is obviously just a specific case, but I
want to kind of use this an example of
the fact that in moving from indirect to
direct methods, we are basically
transitioning a lot of the effort from
the formulation of the problem and the
optimality conditions to kind of
tweaking and making sure that the
optimization actually uh runs
successfully. And so this is why direct
methods are also much more uh
susceptible to uh the quality of the
initial guess uh and all of many other
kind of well uh properties that enable
it to be uh well conditioned.
Uh this is because if you think about it
from the solver perspective um the
solver is basically it doesn't know
we're solving an optimal control problem
right it just sees a random nonlinear
optimization problem and it's trying to
do its best. Um
so for example a classical strategy that
people use to generate better initial
guesses is to first solve a simplified
uh version of the full problem that we
wish to solve. For example, we might be
relaxing some constraints or loosening
some of the constraints and then using
this intermediate solution as a
candidate initial guess for a further uh
kind of iteration of our of our problem.
And so let's do just that. So here what
we're doing is that we first run the
same optimization with the UAX equal
one. So the one that where we were
actually able to solve the problem. And
then let's rerun the 75 version where we
are assuming now we're using the
previous solve as an initial guess for
the second solve.
And what we get is that now this
converges and it does indeed um follow
the bounds on the control.
Again, many of the discussions here are
definitely problem specific, but this is
just a hint of the kind of uh
sophistications that have to come with
uh direct methods.
>> Okay. Any any Yes. um if your like
relaxed version gives you a control
input that's higher than 75 at the
beginning or some state where you're
like outside of bounds at the beginning.
How would that like play out in your
state?
>> So in actually think about it this is
what was happening here right because
the solution with the bounds to one was
actually breaking the 75 bounds. Um
but the point is that initial guesses
don't have to be feasible, right? So it
just have to be an initial point in
solution space for the optimizer to uh
to start iterating from.
>> Okay, does that make sense?
>> Like a time zero like a time zero um or
actually no I can understand
>> uh in general the initial guess doesn't
have to be feasible. So it doesn't
really mind there's no point in in
>> it doesn't really affect the
optimization if it's feasible or not. Of
course if it's feasible probably it's
also a better a better initial guess.
Yeah.
>> Yes.
That's just angle that's just in
radians. But what would the unit be on
the control?
uh we're assuming it's radians and then
we are uh the cost for us is just the
squared of the radians over time
essentially.
Okay. And so
um
yes so this is the basically the
transcription for this example zeral uh
zeral problem uh where we essentially
discretized time we this led to
discretized dynamics where we're
multiplying the original dynamics with
with respect to our time discretization
h and the integrals be some become sums.
Now, of course, here remember we're
looking at these two broad subcategories
of direct methods. Specifically, the
states and control parameterization
methods. And so, notice that here the
optimization variables for our
optimization problems are both the
states and the controls, right? Where
these two are tied together through the
dynamics, which essentially become
constraints that tie controls and states
together.
And these are the results that we just
uh that we just saw.
Okay. And so moving to the other family
of methods which is the control
parameterization methods. Um I would say
that most of the intuition directly
applies. The only two differences are
like specifically relate with the
optimization variables. So now in the
control parameterization methods only
the controls UIs will be our variables
for optimization
and the dynamics essentially become the
mechanism through which we are
implicitly encoding our states by
recursively computing the dynamics over
time. Right? So how we will see now in a
moment on uh on the same example in code
uh we will see how this essentially
boils down to defining an optimization
problem over use uh whereby internally
we have this inner loop where we are
propagating forward our dynamics and
this is also why it's it's referred to
as kind of shooting methods because you
could imagine we are you know
pictorially doing something where we
have an initial state x0 and then the
optimization will choose a set of u so
from u1 to uh un
and then internally we will have this
recursive application of our dynamics
which essentially propagates forwards
our states
but apart from that everything else
stays the same we're again assuming a
uler discretization of time we use uler
integration to uh basically solve
integrate our dynamics
uh with this only distinction that now
the controls are the only optimization
values.
>> Yes.
>> Problems in which you use control
parameization
method versus the previous one.
>> Yeah. So in general I would say that so
note that uh well before
if we wanted to include some fancy state
control so a state constraint so a
constraint on the x since x is an
explicit optimization variable. We could
have just added that constraint. So say
x has to be less or equal than three. We
could just add another constraint saying
x has to be lesser equal than three.
In this other uh formulation, these
states are recursively computed and so
handling state constraints is much uh
more challenging. And so
in kind of at a very high level
generally I would say that if you have
complex state constraints then I would
go for the state and control
parameterization. If you don't uh then
this could be a viable option for
example.
>> Yeah.
Uh well in this case uh both would be
able to
>> but if you have controls then you can
only function or you can only
>> I would say from the perspective of the
optimizer nothing would change here.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right. So this is indeed how we
exactly what we do. Uh so we transcribe
through the control parameization method
the continuous time problem into a
discrete time problem. Uh so let us
let's see how this works in uh in the
code.
Yes. Okay. So the definition of the
problem is exactly the same as before.
So we have the same goal point. We start
from the same origin point. We have the
same time horizon and final time TF. The
the dynamics of so the flow of the river
is exactly the same. Um
and yeah so note that now we define this
dynamics function uh which indeed
encodes are uh dynamic. So the fact that
uh you know the the next x will be the
previous x plus the flow of the river.
We have some bounds on our controls
exactly as we did before. So u has to be
between minus ux and ux. Uh but now the
kind of the crux is in how we define the
constraints. Right? So note that now the
constraints function is only a function
of u because u is the only optimization
variable that we have. And so what we do
here is we have this inner loop where we
are propagating our dynamics forward. Uh
where for
all of our
uh controls in a candidate solution U,
we essentially propagate the dynamics
forward. So we get uh next state and
then we append these uh constraints
um to the to the state at every time.
Note that specifically here we're using
inequality constraints uh whereby in
order to encode the equality constraint
that the final state has to be equal to
ML we have both the fact that the state
has to be less or equal than ML and that
state has to be greater or equal than ML
but you can probably so given kind of
what we're saying here you can imagine
that the sensitivity of this is uh much
greater right because we are basically
uh the optimization variables cannot be
independently tweaked and kind of
snapped to respect the constraints. But
the influence on of the controls on the
overall trajectory is kind of accounted
for uh kind of through this propagation
of the dynamics.
Okay. And so um so what we have now is
that we
encode our initial guess uh which again
is something uh pretty random in this
case. Uh and we have everything to to
solve our our problem. And if we run
this
now with the
umax equal to one. So the same case as
before what we get is the exact same
solution. So it's still able to solve
this um successfully
and if we run the the problem with um
equal to 75 we get that this method
indeed does solve it directly right so
again don't take kind of don't abstract
general conclusions from this specific
run but in general I would say that the
control parameterization methods is less
uh kind of less dependent on the quality
of the initial guess but this is very
much case dependent.
>> Yes.
>> Did it matter at all whether you use
control dependent versus control and
state dependent because you just kind of
wrapped up the state into the controls.
Um
I guess I'm now confused cuz people were
talking about oh it does matter because
when you have like state insurance then
it's important to do X Y and Z but in
this case where you kind of have state
insurance depending on how you want to
look at it it didn't matter. So I guess
if you could clarify
>> yeah it's a good question. Now imagine
that here I hope that kind of it's uh
you agree with me where when you know we
say that kind of here this is something
that the solver needs to run internally
every time it wants to evaluate some
constraints. Right? So for the take the
kind of the solver perspective on this
right we have something we don't know
what it is an optimization problem that
we want to solve and the only knobs we
have to solve this problem are our
optimization variables in this
formulation the only knobs that we have
are the controls and to evaluate how any
tweak in my knobs affects the feibility
and quality of my solution here I need
to propagate forward all of my dynamics
which is different from the previous
transcription where we could turn our
knobs for both the states and the
controls and the yes the states and the
controls and we could verify that in a
way more directly. And so the moment
where we have in this case constraints
are pretty simple mostly bounds. Uh but
the moment we have more sophisticated
constraints you can imagine how this
becomes uh much more uh u kind of
sensitive to my knobs which are my
controls. Does it make sense more or
less? Still, I guess my confusion comes
where it seems like as long as it
doesn't get too complicated, this one's
better because even this is not as um uh
susceptible to a bad initial guess. So,
>> so uh so I don't want you to take this
specific statement and generalize it to
any possible problem. For this problem,
we saw that initialization didn't matter
too much. I would say in general maybe
there is a slight tendency towards
initialization being less relevant here
but in general it's very much problem
dependent. I was thinking in terms of
like rules of thumb is it better to use
the state and control um uh
constraints and do it that way and then
if you know there are really no state
constraints then go this way or is it
better to go this way unless
>> yeah if you like as a rule of thumb if
you have simple or nonstate constraints
then maybe you could try this if you
have complex ones then you might want to
go for the other one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
say this is good cuz it guarantees the
trajectory is like physically feasible
cuz the dynamics are like all the states
are propagated forward based on my
control which is
>> yeah there is some element of that for
sure uh in the sense that dynamics are
implicitly encoding the fact that no
matter how I tune my knobs uh the state
trajectory that I get is feasible uh so
there is some element of that for sure
yeah
>> does the benefit of one or the other
kind of depend a lot on the constraints.
>> Uh yes, I would say it depends a lot on
the constraints and in general the the
problem setting. Yeah. So
one thing I said at the beginning is
that this parameization has fewer
variables and so I kind of hinted at the
fact that they were just smaller
optimization problems. Of course it is
smaller but I am propagating these
dynamics at every time. So trade-offs.
Yeah, I think there was. Okay.
>> Um, since this all depends on kind of
like a numerical propagation, how
important would you say is like uh the
selection of step size?
>> Yeah. So, kind of great followup from
what we're just saying. uh because this
might seem as a smaller optimization
problem but then in this case since I'm
integrating the dynamics forward then I
might have to in order to kind of
uh solve my my problem accurately I
might need to reduce my step size and
discretization and so this would in turn
be a bigger optimization problem. So uh
problem also problem depending matter
but it could it could matter the
discretization
right and also not only the time
discretization but also the way I
integrate my dynamics right um because
in the state space what we're
essentially saying is that we have like
a peace-wise linear uh state trajectory
that we are approximating uh the
continuous time with one with and so
you know the bigger the step size, the
more I have kind of chances of maybe
violating constraints in between and and
things like that.
Does it answer your question? Yeah.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. [snorts]
>> Um or more complicated cost function
is
optimizers
do matter a lot. uh here we were using
like the most uh standard out there. Uh
but definitely also within the sci kind
of ecosystem there are a number of
different optimizers you can choose. Uh
but this is also what I meant with we
are kind of shifting uh mental effort
from formulation of the problem and
optimality conditions to the solution of
a blackbox optimization problem. And
within this uh kind of umbrella term
what I mean is that also the choice of
the optimizer is does play a role.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right. So, basically, you know, we
we saw these two families of
transcription methods where at a high
level, what we want to achieve is
exactly the same thing. So, we want to
go from our continuous time uh optimal
control problem formulation to a
discrete time one which we can solve
through blackbox uh numerical solvers.
uh we saw the uh control uh
parameterization methods which entails
using only the controls as optimization
variables and then in this case the
dynamics are essentially used to
recursively propagate forward in time my
state trajectory. And we saw the state
and control parameterization methods
whereby both states and controls are
optimization variables. And these two
optimization variables are linked
through the dynamics which become
constraints that link these two
variables together.
Of course here we're just scratching the
surface on the types of approaches that
can that can be used. Um in general I
think as your colleague was also
alluding to there are definitely hybrids
of these two methods. For example
multiple shooting is one that I
definitely wanted to mention. Um so if
at a high level if you it's clear what
we are doing in the uh control
primitization methods with this shooting
of the dynamic dynamics forward in time
in multiple shooting. This is basically
a hybrid in the sense that rather than
propagating forward my dynamics from the
initial condition to the final
condition, what I'm doing is I I'm doing
this single shooting on smaller uh
subset of my uh time intervals. So you
could imagine something where I'm
propagating my dynamics forward in time
or only for some subset of the time and
then I'm doing this again and then I'm
doing this again and we introduce
optimization variables at these kind of
dislocation times and the dynamics
become constraints where I want to tie
these two endpoints together. Again high
level picture but what I meant here is
that there are some hybridizations of
these two approaches. Yes.
>> So that allow you to be a little bit
more specific on state constraints
around those joining points
>> in turn you would get that. Yeah.
Of course you know the depending on how
big your
single interval is you might have the
same problems but in general. Yes.
And of course also another discussion
that came up is that here we were
assuming kind of a simple kind of uler
discretization and integration of our
dynamics. We could go for more
sophisticated approximations. Uh for
example leveraging uh polomials which
lead to kind of hermite simpson
collocation schemes and pseudo spectral
methods. Uh and so you know this is kind
of an entire family of of approaches.
Okay, any questions before I move on the
last topic for for today?
>> Okay, great. I mean, I think it's pretty
I hope it's clear kind of the
attractiveness that that direct methods
have, right? because we we had to spend
you know multiple lectures into deriving
these optimality conditions uh before
going into kind of solving them through
numerical methods. Here we're basically
defining the formulation taking that at
face value discretizing it and throwing
it to a numerical optimization method.
And so for the last topic for today is
sequential convex programming which is
uh [snorts] you know arguably actually
one of my favorite uh direct methods
whereby the idea of sequential convex
programming is that until now what we're
doing is that we're taking the
continuous time uh formulation
discretizing it into a nonlinear
optimization problem and then solving it
uh through nonlinear solvers.
Uh, of course, these nonlinear
optimization problems might be
challenging to solve and so sequential
complex programming essentially defines
an iterative strategy to solve this
potentially complex uh nonlinear
optimization uh problem.
And the way it does this is is that we
will be defining as the name kind of
alludes to a sequence of convex problems
which would ultimately and iteratively
lead to the solution of the actual
nonlinear problem which we care about
solving. Why we care about doing this is
because you did a recitation last week
about convex optimization. Convex
recognition is great because we can
solve it easily, fast uh and you know we
are guaranteed to get the global
optimum. And specifically the way we do
this is by introducing
essentially
introducing a surrogate problem of our
original problem that we wish to solve.
And this surrogate problem is
essentially a version where we are uh
linearizing and convexifying the kind of
nonlinear elements in my in our
optimization problem. Right? So and
specifically where the nonlinearities
come from are either the uh usually the
dynamics or the cost.
So the idea of sequential convex
programming is to linearize and
convexify the dynamics and cost around
nominal trajectories.
Solve this problem, get a new nominal
trajectory, reconvexify, relinearize and
keep iterating this until we get a
better solution.
But let's look at this a little bit more
in detail.
Any any questions on the high level u
perspective here?
Yes.
Uh the question is what is the
difference between multiple shooting?
>> You're constantly regularizing and then
you're resolving and you're breaking the
chunks.
>> Uh so here we would basically break
down. So here we would be doing one
optimization solve and we're breaking
down the trajectory over time.
Essentially we have these chunks over
time here and it's it'll be clear now
because we will go through it but here
we are not chopping kind of time but we
are just solving different surrogate
problems over time. So here it's one
single solve here it will be n solves
but here the single solve is a solve of
a nonlinear program. Here we will be
solving recursively uh convex programs.
Does that make sense?
Okay. And so the general idea is that we
are
so assume that g so the cost is convex
for now. Um and let x0 u0 be a nominal
uh trajectory for our states and
controls. In this slides, the uh indices
represent uh iteration steps where
remember this is an iterative algorithm.
So here zero would be the initial guess
at iteration zero
um which will lead to kind of a
surrogate problem which we will solve to
get a nominal guess at iteration one and
keep iterating over over that. So let x0
u z be u a nominal trajectory or more
concretely
so x0 t would essentially be
uh with with t between t0 and tf
uh is is a full function right so we
assume we have a nominal state uh
trajectory
and a nominal
uh control signal.
So the way we want to linearize
so remember what we're doing here is we
are taking the nonlinear program and we
want to turn it into a convex
optimization problem and we do this by
uh linearizing the nonlinear uh dynamics
and specifically we linearize these
dynamics around this nominal trajectory.
So we we do this as usual through tailor
expansion right. So
what we can do and we know is that f of
x u t can be approximated
as f evaluated at the nominal trajectory
x0 u0 t plus plus the
uh jacobian the derivative of the
function f with respect to x times the
difference so x - x0 plus the derivative
with respect to f of f with respect to u
* u - u 0 plus here we would have uh
high order terms
>> yeah x and um not of t
>> I always thought x kn is like at t kn
but so what is x knot at like a t not
equal to t
So here we are introducing this. So for
the coming two slides uh the indices
represent iteration steps because we are
introducing this iterative algorithm. So
for us x not t is a full function at
iteration step zero.
>> It's like the
>> got it. Okay. So that x knot on that
slide is not the same x.
>> Uh which one? where you have x of0 is x
knot but that is not the same x knot
that you were and then you have x of t.
>> Yes, you're right. It's a bit it's
confusing. Yeah, I will update it.
>> But is it clear what we
>> Yes. Yes. I just was
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And so you know here what we did
is we basically linearized the dynamics
around nominal trajectory. Uh and so
basically what we get is that now you
know G is convex. We have now linear
dynamics. And so we basically get a new
problem which is uh now linear, right?
And so what we would do now is we solve
this new problem. We would get a nominal
uh trae a new candidate nominal
trajectory X1 U1 where again here
indices represent iteration steps. And
we would then just repeat this process
whereby
we [clears throat] would now relinearize
our dynamics around this updated nominal
trajectory, solve the linear program,
the linear problem and iterate until we
for example stop improving our um our
solution.
Of
course, in in between these steps, we
always have to discretize, right?
Because we're doing these through direct
methods. And so, at every time, we would
be linearizing the dynamics. We now have
a linear optimal control problem. To
solve this, we discretize it exactly as
we did, which boils down into a convex
optimization problem. Solve this and
keep iterating.
So at a high level sequential complex
programming essentially defines this
scheme where we are given a nonlinear
optimal control problem in continuous
time. To solve this we uh define this
iterative scheme whereby we linearize
the dynamics around a nominal
trajectory. Initially this would just be
an initial guess.
This would then lead us into defining a
continuous time but linear optim optimal
control problem which we discretize
uh in time which leads to a convex
optimization problem which we can solve
reliably efficiently and to the global
minimum which leads to having an updated
nominal trajectory and we keep this
iterating on this loop right until some
termination criteria is uh reached.
Does it make sense what what we're
doing?
Yeah. So basically what we're exploiting
here is the fact that
we are given a nominal trajectory. This
would be x0.
We exploit the fact that we can
basically linearize our nonlinear
dynamics around this trajectory. Meaning
We exploit the fact that deviations
around this trajectory
essentially behave can be well
approximated by some linear dynamics.
And we use these linear dynamics to
essentially define a linear optimal
control problem whereby this would lead
us to maybe an updated guess
say x1 in this case which essentially is
like a minor tweak around our original
solution hopefully in the right
direction and we keep iterating this and
refining our solution until we are
satisfied with uh with our solution.
>> Yes. So you talked about your update for
your new function when you're talking
about the update for the new guesses. So
U12 34 exactly how is that exactly set
per
>> uh and repeat the question.
>> Yeah. So you're iterating in your
function. So which I'm assuming is that
is that function also changing the x and
the I guess.
>> Yes. So this is only in state space. We
would be doing this also in for the
controls. This function is changing
everything. Um, it's a function that
changes both the state and the control.
>> Yes, I'm not sure what you mean by
function exactly, but what I'm saying
here is I was representing the iterative
scheme in state space here.
[snorts]
>> These are our dynamics. Yes.
>> Yes. That's a function describing all of
your dynamics. Um and so that is just
representing how you are going to be
changing the answer in each iteration.
>> Um not really among the iterations. So
these are just the dynamics of our
system. Um what we do is we linearize
these dynamics in order to get a linear
formulation. We solve this linear
formulation to get an updated
trajectory. So what changes from what
brings us from x0 to x1 is one step in
this solve, right? So we're solving a
convex problem which leads to the next
nominal guess.
>> Mhm.
>> A new path and a new control.
>> Yes. And then what we do is we we would
be relearizing around the updated
nominal trajectory
>> and kind of modifying this again to get
the next two and so forth.
Okay, so I want to quickly
show this in code as well.
So usual problem. Um what changes here
is that now we are linearizing our
dynamics. We're we are not doing this
analytically. We're using jacks to
linearize our dynamics. So we have this
uh function here which essentially
computes the Jacobians uh of our
dynamics. So these two terms which are
essentially two matrices right this
would be a matrix A this would be a
matrix B.
Um
and once we have the and so we define
the linearized dynamics as the original
dynamics evaluated at uh the nominal
guess
this one here
plus
uh the derivative of f with respect to x
times the displacement in x plus the
derative of f with respect to u time the
uh displacement in u
and and so once we have this we
basically define our um
sequential convex programming
iterations. So here we assume we have a
maximum number of iterations that is
100. So for each of our iteration steps
or loops uh we would be defining an
optimal control problem which
essentially entails our x's and u's for
now u ignore the s we have our controls.
So we have our cost function, we have
our linearized dynamics, we have our
initial and terminal conditions, we have
our state and control constraints and we
can just uh solve it
and we see that kind of this leads to
the solution of the of the same problem.
Okay, one thing. Yes,
>> the start. Didn't we come up with a
nonlinear programming solution to it?
Like I'm confused when you want to use
SCP instead of the original method.
>> So the problem is that the original
nonlinear optimization problem might be
just very hard to solve. And so SCP is
basically a strategy to solve nonlinear
optimization problems which relies kind
of in an inner loop on a convex uh
optimization which is fast and reliable.
And so you could see this as a
sophisticated way of solving those uh
nonlinear optimization problems which is
quite effective and I would say most
state-of-the-art approaches nowadays use
something on along these flavors.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. How do we know that linearizing the
dynamics and then using like convex
optimization to solve each sub problem
will give us like closer to like get us
a better solution? Yeah, it's a great
question and I would say so this is also
where kind of most uh state-of-the-art
so what differentiates between uh you
know a naive implementation of SCP and a
state-of-the-art implementation of SCP
uh so where this difference lies and
this is because um
the so at the overall high level picture
kind of SCP describes a scheme where we
are given an initial trajectory guess
somehow
u we linearize the non-convexities
around this nominal guess as we just
saw. Forget this box for now. Uh we
discretize it. We solve it through
convex optimization. If we're happy,
then we're done. If we're not happy, we
start again this loop. Again, ignore
this box. What I meant between
difference between um
naive implementation and a
state-of-the-art implementation exactly
lies in these two boxes whereby since we
are introducing this surrogate problem
which is on one hand easy to solve
because it's convex but it could
introduce some additional problems and
two specifically relevant ones are
artificial invisibility and artificial
unboundedness. So since we are have
we're introducing a surrogate problem
this surrogate problem might be
infeasible while the overall non
nonlinear problem might actually be
feasible
and the other problem artificial
unboundedness is that the convex problem
might just lead us into a situation
where the optimal solution of the convex
problem just leads us to minus infinity
for example and so there are different
ways in which one could um approach
this. So typically to handle artificial
unboundedness
uh you want to ensure that you're in
solving the individual iterate you don't
diverge too much from your nominal guess
and this is because since we're
linearizing the dynamics um these
linearization is only accurate in a
neighborhood of the nominal trajectory
and so this is where concepts like trust
regions are introduced in order to
basically
mass massage the convex problem such
that we are not moving too much from the
original solution.
For example, a trust region constraint
could be something where
I want to stay within a certain distance
from my nominal trajectory.
And the other topic is the one of uh
artificial invisibility.
Uh and typically this is handled through
slack variables. So a slack variable is
something where say we have
[clears throat] a constraint that our u
has to be smaller than a uax. We could
add an additional optimization variable
s uh which allows us to kind of loosen
this constraint if needed but we would
be penalizing this in the cost. So like
an updated cost could be the original
cost plus s squ for example.
Now this is kind of a long detour uh but
does this kind of go in the direction of
what you're asking?
Yeah. And so now to conclude if you're
seeing those s variables before this was
indeed the slack variable. So we were
adding introducing this fictitious
[snorts]
uh optimization variable s which we are
adding to our uh bound constraints u uh
and in the cost. So we are penalizing
the slack variable. And if you look at
the results of the optimization, we see
how the slack variable indeed kind of
decreases over time because initially
for the optimization, apparently it is
helpful to violate some of the
constraints, but then since we're
penalizing them, this kind of reduces
and ultimately goes to zero.
Okay, any questions on this?
Okay, perfect. And so, uh, yeah, just to
wrap up, this is a nice quote from, uh,
Professor Tedre at MIT, uh, where Centry
says, as you begin to play with these
algorithms on your own problems, you
might feel like you're an emotional
roller coaster. And this is because,
again, as we were hinting at before, we
are kind of shifting a lot of the mental
effort into tweaking the nonlinear
optimization problem such that it gives
us a solution in the end. Uh and so I'm
sure you will be going on this roller
coaster also through your pets. Um and
this kind of concludes the openloop um
portion of our road map and on Monday
we'll be moving towards closed loop
methods through dynamic programming.
Thank you.